well a family left heartbroken and angry
tonight after they say crews from a
flooring company working in their
neighborhood took their dog right from
their yard the beloved pup later found
dead victoria saha has the sad sad story
bamboo is being remembered by his family
as the bulldog that loved to cuddle and
snore really loud
he's family to us he's all our kids know
monday evening bamboo was outside in his
yard in the southwest valley but never
came back inside and with the heat
angelica schming was worried we were
looking for him all night
the next morning i was doing door to
door until a neighbor showed her
surveillance video that would change
everything footage shows workers from a
flooring company who were at the house
next door taking bamboo and put him in a
truck minutes later the same white truck
drives away the next day bamboo's owners
wanted answers we asked you nicely to
just give him back or just tell us the
truth and you lied to us
constantly schming tells me the workers
kept giving her different stories one
saying they realized bamboo might be
microchipped and he was dropped off
outside their gate but on tuesday
evening bamboo's lifeless body was
discovered miles from home in the north
las vegas area an english bulldog can't
walk that far in this heat he's old
it's just so traumatizing to think about
it like how
his last
minutes were temperatures for tuesday
were 104. this business owner did not
care
he just took someone else's dog and now
he's there
in this heat
i made numerous attempts to contact the
flooring company and eventually they
denied their involvement
that was victoria saha reporting metro
police told her that this was initially
being investigated as a property crime
because in our state dogs are considered
property but now that the dog has died
those circumstances have changed an
autopsy is the next step in the
investigation